is that awesome
I think it's all worth it
thank you
oh my goodness me look who's at the
Forefront of that wall the man himself
your family and your legacy yeah
absolutely yes
[Music]
it's the beginning of a new generation
for bottles Italian line we revamped the
restaurant Old World charm for the
Modern Age gone are the outdated
portraits
replaced with a design that's cozy and
Rusty I feel like it's so big in here
like there's so much room by upgrading
the stuffy Deco we've created a space
that's open and inviting fit for family
and friends alike I love these lights I
just think that finished it off so
pretty and now let's get all the team in
here
right okay
for me this level of uh confusion in
terms of Robert's
and Henry we have one person in control
now and that person is
me we're going to run the ship in the
right direction this is family here
okay let's bring that family feeling
back let's recharge this place and let's
knock it out of the park tonight
let's set sail I didn't think I was
gonna cry
yep we're here for you Robert will be
here tonight but is up to each and every
one of you to prove that he doesn't need
to be here amen 100 agree yes let's go
guys
we got this right good job we got this
hello sir customer sat upstairs having
dinner with a cricket from USA Today an
influential critic
can you explain exactly this man who you
are no I'm your brother
ah I would never guessed
man so that was your brother you just
cooked for yeah my big question are you
gonna support him absolutely I mean you
got a team behind you dad taught us
right okay so let's [__] do it do you
want this absolutely I would have did if
I didn't want it so Robert's house he's
got to stay out and I'm going to make
sure we both are this is your room I
know that's your room
right I know no the critic enjoyed the
future well your brother enjoyed the
food but you need to find that voice
step up and nothing was scared of and
grab the ball by the horse definitely
will okay and last time I come back I
want to see you in charge
Gordon Ramsay is a hell of a man
thank you the passion he has helped
people is
immeasurable
keep him out of there would you oh yeah
thank you
he's giving me the right tools to
continue my dad's Legacy and grow
bothers even bigger this family has been
severely wounded but if I can Empower
Logan we may have some direction Amber
Let's uh two minutes together please
tired tired
tough day right tough day Russians are
tough things to operate yes there's one
thing that's going on inside your
restaurant is that it's been run by too
many people because you can't use a
restaurant to mend a broke relationship
it doesn't work and the pressure it puts
on Logan
standing there and his angst and his
frustration
and it's all about his heart how bad for
the business she is
give me an insight to Autumn strengths
what's she good at
um
what does she walk through the door with
what does he bring to the business
give me an insight to Autumn strengths
but what does she walk through the door
with what does she bring to the business
I don't know
[Music]
you can't think of one thing and I can
see you're getting emotional because
there's no contribution turning up for
work big deal I don't think there's many
people in that business that can work
with your sister or who want to work
with her
you had to stop letting her bring you
and your children down
[Music]
come on it's so important to talk yes
you're an amazing son
I had an amazing daughter yes it's time
to look after each other
sometimes that means letting others go
think about it okay okay come here help
okay
I'm gonna think about
New Beginnings
the past is gone
I'm gonna start fresh
and I'm not going to let anyone stand in
the way of that
with progress continuing on the front of
house uh Autumn take a seat with us okay
I now need to deal with what I believe
is seafarer's biggest problem how are
you I'm good I'm okay yeah my goal
Autumn is to get this restaurant
successful I wanted to be I wanted to be
successful would that restaurant run
awesome better without you
I don't think I don't think so no I just
feel like I'm like ostracized gamber's
in control of everything yeah I know she
was put to be the whatever the head
manager do you think you could run the
Russian better than Amber
yes yes I can I spend a lot of time here
but
I'm not included in anything but there
are issues there Way Beyond the
restaurant you know that yeah it started
at our childhood and my dad he always
gave me the brunt of everything so she
wasn't anywhere near her as much oh no
sir I'm sorry about that but it's almost
like you're venting and using the
restroom to get back at your family
foreign
launched that restaurant
you take a sabbatical and we get your 20
investment coming on a monthly basis how
would that make you feel no I don't want
to take no no sir
your sister and your mum need to decide
a Way Forward I'd have to think about it
I guess
Autumn is clearly reluctant to step away
from the restaurant and at the end of
the day I can't be the one to make that
decision for this family
if this doesn't work you're taking her
down I will not fail I will not take her
down I won't no matter what sacrifice I
have to make I won't do it I am going to
make this happen with or without
anyone's help I'm going to be okay it's
not looking good yes it is
looking good for the fact that we are
still trying and we have not given up if
we give up now what will we do I'm the
answer to give up it's awesome to be
reasonable stop being so stubborn I'm
blinded by the office
you are bringing your daughters
down and you've put them at risk and
over the last 18 months all you've done
his butt heads fight and scream and
upset each other no restaurant is worth
that it's one thing for you to risk all
this but your two daughters sat in the
back seat I'm telling you I think you'll
be unfair
you're taking advantage of the
unconditional love
that you're two amazing daughters
show you I'm sorry
Shane is acting defensive because she
can't see her own problems she's gonna
hit a brick wall soon I don't know when
but something's gonna click and she'll
understand
that she is the driving force behind
this mess and the responsibility lies
with her not her daughters Gordon I'm
getting news that Shane is leaving the
restaurant right now one thing you never
do
is jump ship where is she she's in her
car with her mother oh my god let's go
what's wrong I'm amazed you want to
throw the towel in now
but tell me what's wrong tell me what
you mean I feel like you've given up on
us you know I've given up on you oh
that's unfair I know damn well that
you're not gonna like everything I'm
doing I I get that it's not about
rubbing your face in it it's about
helping you have you seen Shane I don't
know about this for you you know what
I'm saying you made it man you didn't
took the kids trying to separate the
family from the business
because there's two different things
going on here we have a family that's
hurting and a business is struggling if
I get the business back up to speed then
the family don't have to hurt if you
think that's been unfair I'm sorry but
there's two different things in here and
with 38 restaurants and five kids of my
own I'm not going to bring them into my
business right I have to separate it so
if Chelsea's there for the next 18
months there needs to be a there needs
to be a path set and if you don't think
that's valid then I'm I'm out of there
you know what I'm sorry and I'm not
rubbing your face in it I know it's hard
to hear I'm really sorry
I'm really sorry come here come out of
there
come on
we're gonna do this okay come on hey
you're a great man we're gonna do this
I'm not gonna let that family struggle
I'm trying to separate the issues so you
can go on holiday yes you can have a
vacation you can have a weekend together
okay
Grand come here please come on
we are going to say that it's family we
are going to save this restaurant okay
okay I'm here to help thanks for help
out loud so many times I'm I'm gonna I'm
gonna help I'm gonna help you but I also
want to protect the family I'm really
sorry let me help you
okay come on